>> GOOD EVENING EVERYONE.
WELCOME TO "THE NEXT
REVOLUTION".
THIS IS THE HOME OF POSITIVE
POPULISM , PRO-WORKER,
PRO-FAMILY, PRO-COMMUNITY, AND
ESPECIALLY PRO-AMERICA. HERE
WE GO AGAIN.
SELF-RIGHTEOUS SANCTIMONIOUS
DEMOCRATS WITH THEIR AND WAS
LECTURES ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
EQUITY AND INCLUSION BUT
RACIST AT THE DROP OF A HAT
PROGRAM CHALLENGE THE CLIMATE
YOUR RACIST.
SO WE SEE WHATEVER THEY ACCUSE
EVERYONE ELSE OF THEY ARE
GUILTY OF THE EXACT SAME THING
AND WORSE.
LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL
AMERICA SECOND-LARGEST CITY
AND BY DEMOCRATS FOR DECADES.
NOW ENGULFED IN A RACISM
SCANDAL OF THEIR OWN MAKING AS
THEY ALWAYS SAY WHEN THEY TELL
YOU WHO THEY ARE, BELIEVE
THEM.
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SHOOTINGS OF MEXICAN AMERICANS
"A LOT OF LITTLE SHORT DARK
PEOPLE WHO ARE SO UGLY.
HE ADOPTED BLACK SON A LITTLE
MONKEY.
HIS FATHER WHO IS GAY SHE
CALLS A LITTLE BIT.
HOMOPHOBIA FROM THOSE WHO
NEVER STOPPED LEAVING THE
RAINBOW FLAGS INQUIRY DID NOT
SLIP THROUGH THE BIGOTED SLUR.
FOR THREE DAYS MARTINIS TRYING
TO CLING TO POWER WITH HER
$200,000 SALARY AND THE OTHER
COUNCILMEMBERS IN MASHED IN
THE FILTH HAVE A NO SHAME?
NO.
THEY DON'T.
BECAUSE THEY TRULY HAVE
CONVINCED THEMSELVES THAT
THERE MORAL SUPERIORITY
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEY SAY OR
DO.
REVEALED THIS WEEK THE MOST
SANCTIMONIOUS OF THEM
ALL, OBAMA WITH HIS VERY OWN
DEPLORABLE MOMENTS BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS IN JUNE SMEARING
REPUBLICANS TO A GLOBAL
AUDIENCE "SOMETIMES IT JUST
TURNS OUT THEY ARE
MEAN, RACIST AND SEXIST AND
ANGRY.
THE PERIOD UNDILUTED HATRED
AND CONTEMPT FOR FELLOW
AMERICANS AND HE PRESENTED TO
REPRESENT CYNICAL FRAUD THAT
SHOCKED THAT CHLORINE WITH NO
SUCH THING AS RED STATES AND
BLUE STATES JUST UNITED STATES
NOW WITH BIO SWEEPING
STEREOTYPING THIS COMPLETE
CHARLATAN CALLING THE MEANING
RACIST WHEN HIS OWN DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS, MEXICANS DARK AND
UGLY AND COMPARING BLACK
CHILDREN TO MONKEYS SHAME ON
THE DEMOCRATS AND OBAMA AND
HIS PEOPLE WHO USE RACISM AND
SEXISM AND HOMOPHOBIA AS A
POLITICAL WEAPON TO DO NOTHING
TO CONFRONT WITHIN THEIR OWN
RANKS.
BIDEN WAS WITH NANCY PELOSI ON
WEDNESDAY FOR A FUNDRAISER HE
WOULD NOT HAVE SET FOOT IN THE
CITY UNLESS THE RACIST
DEMOCRATS RESIGN.
IS ANYONE THERE HE REFUSED TO
CONFRONT THEM?
BIRDS OF A FEATHER FLOCK
TOGETHER.
>> YOU CANNOT GO TO A 711 OR
DUNKIN' DONUTS UNLESS YOU HAVE
A SLIGHT INDIAN ACCENT.
>> THEY ARTICULATE AND BRIGHT
AND CLEAN.
>> THESE KIDS ARE JUST AS
BRIGHT AND TALENTED AS WHITE
KIDS.
YOU CAN'T FIGURE THAT OUT THEN
YOU AREN'T BLACK.
>> THAT IS WHO BIDEN IS.
LIKE THE DEMOCRATS IN L.A.
CITY COUNCIL WITH THAT RACIST
MINDSET.
AFTER THEY HAVE BEEN SO
PATHETIC ABOUT ALL THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR NEWSOM
WITH THE STATEMENT THAT DID
NOT EVEN JUST THAT THEY RESIGN
WE KNOW PERFECTLY WELL IF A
REPUBLICAN CALLED MEXICANS
UGLY THEY WOULD BE PUTTING UP
BILLBOARDS IN FLORIDA BUT WHEN
IT IS HIS CORRUPT CRONIES IN
HIS OWN BACKYARD BARELY A
WHISPER.
SPEAKING OF CORRUPTION, AND
THE MEETING THAT WAS LEAKED
DEMOCRATIC COUNCILMEMBER UNION
LEADER WERE PLOTTING AND
SCHEMING TO GERRYMANDER
DISTRICTS LONG RACIAL LINES
WHAT IS THE UNION LEADER DOING
UP ELECTION BOUNDARIES?
WHAT ABOUT PROTECTING
DEMOCRACY?
MAY ENDLESSLY ACCUSE
REPUBLICANS OF GERRYMANDERING
OF COURSE THEY DO BECAUSE THEY
ALWAYS KEEP ACCUSE OTHERS OF
THE EXACT SAME THING.
JUST THIS WEEK AFTER YEARS OF
NONSTOP ELECTION MEDDLING ON
INTERFERENCE WE LEARNED THEY
WENT TO A FOREIGN COUNTRY
DOESN'T INTERFERE IN OUR
MIDTERMS.
BUT THIS CURRENT GENERATION OF
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS THE DAYS
THAT YOU COULD DISAGREE OVER
POLICY BUT RESPECT THE
INTEGRITY THEY DON'T BELIEVE
ANYONE IS GOOD ARE DECENT OR
WELL-MEANING OR PRINCIPLE THAT
THEMSELVES.
ANYONE ON THE OTHER SIDE IS
RACIST OR SEXIST ARE MEAN AND
ANGRY YES WE ARE.
THAT THESE HATEFUL AND
DIVISIVE DEMOCRATS HAVE PULLED
UP OUR CIVIC DISCOURSE AND
THAT THEY TURN POLITICS INTO A
PERPETUAL WAGE FILLED WAR AND
ABOVE ALL ANGRY AT THE BRAZEN
DOUBLE STANDARD OF HYPOCRISY
OF RACE AND DEMOCRACY OF
EVERYTHING.